[Music]
how do you like a behind-the-scenes look
at one of nature's most luxurious
full-service hippo spas our dominant
male hippo customer has already arrived
here at the mazuma spring Kenya Africa
what the carp goes right to work it uses
its wide rasping mouth to scour the
hippos hi
the hippo get squeaky clean skin and
fish gets a rich buffet dead skin algae
and parasites
[Music]
how about that tail that looks kind of
like a toilet brush the cichlid fish
takes care of that how about no how can
I say this discreetly the hippos
hindquarters where the hippo produces
hippo done the marble fish eagerly dives
in here especially when the hippo is in
done production mode the barbel is so
eager for what the hippo is trying to
get rid of that they race after him like
an autograph secret a sing a rock star
finally the hippo opens its mouth home
of the good stuff
and the fish Russian like hungry
shoppers at a half-off bake sale
what the hippo has enjoyed the full
treatment and after it's done enjoys a
relaxing yarn of relief
[Music]